restaurants have traditionally enjoyed a
crucial and privileged place in the
history of dating providing us with
enough privacy to get to know one
another and enough public scrutiny to
help us feel safe as we do so the food
and drink has largely been an excuse but
what we decide to eat and drink together
on a date isn't merely incidental to the
real task of mutual understanding it too
is rich in psychological clues
communicating messages about who we are
and what we might be like over a
lifetime how we order on a date can in a
minor key belong to the task of winning
someone else over to our cause so let's
think of a number of ways of ordering
food and drink that suggests intriguing
and complex things about our identities
a large mixed salad accompanied by a
plate of fries on the side we could eat
the fries with our fingers and
occasionally dip them in the vinaigrette
this would communicate that were pretty
sensible in many ways with a keen eye
for restraint and a decent amount of
self-control but at the same time it
would suggest that we aren't afraid of
our own more impish desires
we'd be hinting that we were a sound
blend of the mischievous and the prudent
that we had enough self mastery and
obedience to have earned the right for
occasional moments of unorthodox
indulgence fish fingers offer children's
menu
through our order we'd be implying that
we could recognize without anxiety the
claim of the more childish parts of our
personalities but that we were
sufficiently grown up to be undisturbed
by their presence but the order might
work best if we combined it with an
obviously sophisticated starter or
dessert and no one can be free of the
legacy of their early past we'd be
saying through our food what matters is
the maturity with which we can
acknowledge and navigate around it
almost nothing after putting in our bear
order we might allow ourselves to say
with beguiling frankness that we were
simply too nervous to eat this would be
importantly different from and much more
attractive than merely ordering a normal
amount then pushing it idly around our
plate
we'd be showing that we were upfront in
revealing that the date meant a lot to
us and that there was in our eyes
nothing shameful about being anxious in
relation to an event that might turn out
to be hugely significant our inability
to countenance any dessert whatsoever
not even a few berries would be a
flattering way of sending out a message
that we were in the company of someone
with a power maybe to alter our lives
and reduce
the deep red drink would be a symbol of
independence we'd be making a rather
unconventional order through it this not
being what people typically ask for in a
restaurant but it wouldn't be willful or
crazy either we just be quietly
asserting that we didn't mind appearing
a little odd for the sake of getting
something we genuinely liked we would be
via the glass saying that we were our
own sort of people
the chicken but we dad with a large
smile and a huge polite and patient
explanation ideally without the ginger
in the garlic and with the sauce on the
side in a little jug if that was even
vaguely acceptable to the guys in the
kitchen who he really hoped wouldn't be
put out by this sort of in our words
unbearably fussy request
through this kind of order we'd be
communicating that we knew our tastes
were complicated and off the beaten
track but also that we had the self
belief and requisite charm to lay out
our desires calmly and without unjú or
grating petulance everyone in
relationships turns out in time to
harbor a host of very particular
requirements no one however casual they
might appear at first is ever really
easy in the long term so what matters
hugely is if we've learnt the art of
communicating our needs clearly with
grace without entitlement or willfulness
with the wit and will of the best
teacher an accomplishment there can be
perfect opportunities to display in our
approach to the ordering of the main
course
something we hadn't ever ordered but
that was sitting on our dates plate and
that looked especially appealing and
that we'd very sweetly asked if we could
have a bit of
in this way we'd be communicating that
we were ready to step over conventional
barriers in the name of friendship but
we understood there were certain
standard obstacles to intimacy but that
we were interested in finding a few
playful ways of getting past them
possibly later that night in the end the
success of a date will not hang entirely
on what's eaten or drunk but nor should
we ignore how much can be communicated
through such details and therefore how
legitimate it always is to reflect at
depth on more apparently minor sides of
love to learn more about love try our
set of cards that help answer that
essential question who should I be with
you